a hundred trillion neutrinos are passing
through your body every second seriously
they're like subatomic ninjas these
neutrinos are an elementary particle
with such a low mass that we don't
actually know exactly what that mass is
I can tell you it's not zero and I can
give you a decent upper bound but that's
it that low mass allows them to travel
at nearly the speed of light even
weirder they can change from one type of
neutrino to another as they travel
that's how we know their Mass isn't zero
neutrinos are also electrically neutral
which is why they tend not to interact
with anything we might see one or two a
day in a giant detector like this so
neutrinos do interact occasionally when
they deem another particle worthy of
their Wrath